تحلق بارتفاعات اعلى من ارتفاع الطائرات
التجاريه
وقد تحصل هنالك اخطاء وقد تخرج عن السيطره
بسبب عوامل في تغيير اتجاه الرياح حاليا
الامر
غير معروف اذا ما كان هذا المنطاد قد دخل
اجواء الامريكيه بطريقه متعمده ام لا لكن
بالتاكيد هو تذكير للدول الاخرى في ان
تختلط وان تكون متيقظه حول النشاطات التي
تحصل في اجوائها طيب وكيف يمكن اذا التاكد
والفصل بينه دخل بالخطا كما في الروايه
الصينيه ام كما في الشكوك الامريكيه انه
هو لغرض التجسس
حاليا نحن نفتقر الى بعض العناصر التقنيه
التي تمكننا من الاجابه على هذا السؤال
لكن علينا ان نتذكر شيء واحد انه تحت
الاطار القانوني الذي يحكم الملاحه الجويه
فان كل دوله سياده على المجال الجوي وليس
لا يحق لاي طائره مدنيه او عسكريه ان
تخترق او تحلق في اجواء دوله اخرى بدون اي
ترخيص او بدون اتفاق خاص وفي هذه الحاله
وفي اذا لم يكن هنالك في هذه الحاله لم
يكن هنالك مثل هذا الاتفاق
تقولين بما انه يحلق على ارتفاعات اعلى
بكثير من الطائرات المدنيه فيمكن ان
تفقد السيطره عليه هل معنى ذلك بان هذا
المنطاد برايك يبقى تائها ولن يتمكن
احد من السيطره عليه الا باسقاطه
لغرض حسب القانون المدني وقانون الملاحه
يجب ان يكون هنالك اعتبارات للامن
للمحيط به هذا البالون او المطاط لا يمثل
خطرا كبيرا لكنه قد يمثل احتماليه انه هو
ان يتم ربما اسقاط هذا المنطاد وهو يحلق
فوق البحار حيث لا يكون هنالك الكثير من
حركه الطيران ربما طيب وفق القانون الدولي
الجوي كيف يمكن الفصل الان قانونيا في هذه
القضيه بين الدولتين هناك تعامل من
البنتاغون وهناك محاوله لدراسه الاحتمالات
في التعامل مع الامر وهناك تحرك دبلوماسي
ايضا بالنسبه للولايات المتحده ولكن من
ناحيه القانون الدولي ما الذي سيترتب
قانونيا على هذه الخطوه
النقاشات
ربما قليله بين الولايات المتحده والصين
لان المناطيل حتى لو انها اصبحت ربما
ادوات لا يتم استخدامها للتجسس في دول
اخرى لكن بامكانها ان تخلق توتر
الدبلوماسيا كبيرا وتعطي ايضا نوع من
التوتر الكبير بين الدول العظمى الان
الطريقه الوحيده لحل هذه المشكله هو ان
تقوم الصين والولايات المتحده بان يجلس مع
بعضهما البعض ان يجدا حلا لهذه القضيه
الذي يحلق في اجواء الولايات المتحده بدون
رخصه
الايروتوكريتو الخبيره في القانون الجوي
الدولي من لندن شكرا جزيلا لك